[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
und ihren live stream zu aktuellen
ereignissen und heute schaut das land
wieder mal nach berlin auf die
ergebnisse der bund länder konferenz
bundeskanzlerin merkel und die
ministerpräsidenten der bundesländer
sitzen zusammen oder saßen zusammen fast
den ganzen nachmittag wir warten seitdem
auf ein ergebnis immer wieder ist
teilweise durchgesickert aber natürlich
wirklich was beschlossen wurde wissen
wir es gleich wenn die pressekonferenz
losgeht und auf diesen start warten wir
eigentlich sollte das ganze schon viel
früher beginnen um 11 uhr wollten sich
die verantwortlichen zusammenschalten
aber das hat gedauert und da möchte ich
doch mal meine kollegin nicole diekmann
in unserem hauptstadtstudio fragen
nicole woran hat das gelegen dass es
dann doch immer später wurde
ja es gibt jedes mal bei diesem treffen
kann man ja inzwischen sagen diverse
papiere die kursieren hier ist papier 1
dass wir heute nachmittag bekamen und
hier ist papier 2 dass wir vor wenigen
minuten bekommen haben und im ersten
papier waren es noch elf punkte im
zweiten papier sind es nur noch neun
punkte und das zeigt schon mal daran
wurde noch mal gearbeitet und es gibt
zwei punkte in denen ganz offensichtlich
änderungen mittlerweile nachzulesen sind
der eine
da geht es um die
der radius da wo er war ja schon den
ganzen nachmittag über immer mehr durch
gesicht versichert der gelten soll ab
einer gewissen 7 tages instanz innerhalb
dessen man sich nur noch entfernt von
seinem eigenen wohnhaus oder von seiner
wohnung bewegen darf im ersten entwurf
stand das bei einer inzidenz von 200 das
heißt 200 neuinfektionen bei 100000
einwohner innen binnen sieben tagen
da sollte dann darüber nachgedacht
werden von seiten der länder die er
zuständig sind dass dieser radius gelten
soll und nun im zweiten papier ist diese
instanz runter geschraubt worden da
steht jetzt ganz klar inland greifen mit
einer 7 tages instanz von über 100
neuinfektionen ist der bewegungsradius
auf 15 kilometer um den wohnort zu
begrenzen
da wird also keine kein spielraum mehr
den ländern gelassen sondern das soll
dann geltend das zeigt also darüber hat
man anscheinend heute länger diskutiert
und der zweite punkt keine große
überraschung nach den letzten tagen auch
eigentlich nach den letzten wochen der
debatten betrifft die schulen mit auf-
oder schulen zu das ist ja der große
knackpunkt im moment in der debatte im
ersten entwurf hieß es die schulen
sollen genauso wie der lok da die
schulschließungen sollen genauso wie der
lok dauern bis ende januar anhalten das
ist nun in der zweiten version des
papiers raus da sind jetzt die
kultusminister innen aufgefordert ein
konzept zu erarbeiten das es erlaubt die
schulen möglichst schnell wieder zu
öffnen aber es ist kein datum mehr in
diesem papier vorgesehen das ganze
müssen aber sagen ist grad noch
vorläufig glaube ich weil was
tatsächlich beschlossen wurde werden wir
gleich bei der pressekonferenz hören es
gab jedoch viel streit im vorhinein
dieses bund länder treffen was ist dazu
den durchgedrungen worüber wurde da
besonders hart diskutiert und wo
verliefen auch die konfliktlinien ja
ehrlich gesagt war der streit diesmal
nicht so groß wie in den vergangenen
monaten
war ja eigentlich auch schon seit tagen
klar nach den wortmeldungen die im
vorfeld eines solchen treffens ja immer
von unterschiedlich
ministerpräsidentinnen zu lesen zu hören
waren in zeitungen in sendungen in
interviews es war eigentlich klar dass
der lok dorn also die geschlossenen
geschäfte die geschlossenen restaurants
die cafés dass das unstrittig ist dass
es bis zum 31 januar mindestens so
fortgeführt wird und daran scheint es
auch heute überhaupt überhaupt keine
diskussionen großartig gegeben zu haben
wie ich eben schon gesagt habe es gibt
unterschiedliche auffassungen darüber
wie man mit den schulen umgehen soll
auch mit den kitas in vielen ländern
sind die kitas ja komplett dicht dann
gibt es andere länder wie zum beispiel
berlin da gibt es die notbetreuung das
ist das ist eine große frage gewesen
und eben wie es eben auch schon gesagt
habe dieser radius jetzt sehe ich gerade
aus den augenwinkeln ich mach es kurz
die pressekonferenz geht los wir
sprechen einfach nach er weiter ja söder
ministerpräsidenten von bayern und
berlins regierender bürgermeister
michael müller nehmen und platz und
werden uns jetzt sagen was sie
beschlossen haben berichten jetzt über
die ergebnisse ihrer beratungen
ich habe meine damen und herren von
meiner seite aus noch ein gesundes neues
jahr ist er das erste mal dass wir uns
sehen es war klar dass wir sehr zu
beginn der des jahres schon uns wieder
treffen werden denn die verordnung die
wir im dezember erlassen haben gehen ja
nur bis zum 10
januar und um die vorbereitung treffen
zu können mussten wir uns ein bild von
der lage machen
dazu haben wir gestern eine
expertenanhörung vorgeschaltet bei denen
der chef des robert koch instituts
wieder uns nochmal darauf hingewiesen
hat dass durch die weihnachts und
silvester neujahrstage eine klare
datenlage über die wirkliche instituts
in deutschland erst
ab 17 januar etwa zu gewinnen ist das
heißt wir ahnen und wissen dass sie
incidents deutlich über 50 ist aber wie
genau sie ist kann zur zeit nicht genau
abgesehen werden
unser ziel bleibt es natürlich weiter
unter 50 infizierte pro 100000
einwohnern in sieben tagen zu kommen
warum damit die nachverfolgung der
infektionsketten wieder möglich ist dass
gewinnt noch einmal an bedeutung weil
wir von einer mutation des virus
kenntnis erlangt haben
aus großbritannien geben die sich
schneller verbreitet und damit mehr
infektionen pro kontakt verursacht das
heißt also hier müssen wir besonders
vorsichtig sein
daraus entsteht noch mal eine neue und
besondere lage wir haben gestern unter
den experten stellvertretend für die
universitätsklinika professor krömer den
chef der charité in berlin gehört der
uns nochmal darauf hingewiesen hat unter
welch hoher belastung die
intensivstationen in der bundesrepublik
deutschland jetzt arbeiten und sie
wissen dass wir immer von einer
überforderung des gesundheitswesens
ausgegangen von einer verhinderung der
ausgegangen sind und wir sind jetzt sehr
sehr stark doch in grenzsituationen an
einigen krankenhäusern das heißt auch
das hat uns noch einmal dazu bewogen
heute weitreichende beschlüsse zu fassen
und alle die argumente die ich eben
vorher genannt habe wir wollen die
beschlüsse die wir im dezember gefasst
haben bis zum 31 januar verlängern
und wir werden in einigen bereichen die
beschlüsse auch noch einmal verschaffen
müssen aus den gründen die ich eben
genannt habe ein grund ist eben dass die
kontakte noch weiter reduziert werden
müssen weil wir ja auch gesehen haben
dass wir in den letzten wochen eben
nicht so weit die inzidenz senken
konnten
und weil wir eben durch das virus und
seine mutationen noch einmal
unsicherheiten haben das heißt wir
fordern alle bürgerinnen und bürger auf
die kontakte auf das absolut notwendige
minimum zu beschränken
und wir werden in erweiterung der
bisherigen beschlüsse private
zusammenkünfte im kreis der angehörigen
des eigenen hausstandes und mit maximal
einer weiteren nicht im haushalt
lebenden personen nur gestatten das ist
eine deutliche reduktion gegenüber der
jetzt bestehenden regelung von fünf
personen aus zwei haushalten
wir sehen uns zu dieser rückkehr zu der
märz maßnahme eben aus den genannten
gründen genötigt und glauben dass sie
richtig ist auch wenn sie für die
menschen hart ist wir wollen dass
niemand alleine ist deshalb eine nicht
im haus stand lebende person aber
ansonsten die kontakte innerhalb des
hausstandes wir werden betriebskantinen
schließen wo immer die arbeitsabläufe
das zu lassen
es bleibt die abgabe von mitnahme
fähigen speisen und getränken möglich
aber ein verzehr vor ort wird untersagt
und wir appellieren noch einmal an die
arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgeber die
großzügigen home office möglichkeiten
weiter gelten zu lassen oder neue zu
schaffen um den grundsatz wir bleiben zu
hause um auch den öffentlichen
personennahverkehr zu entlasten wirklich
umsetzen zu können
wir haben uns im blick auf die ja schon
früher beschlossen hotspot strategie was
passiert in landkreisen mit über 200
infektionen noch zu einer weiteren
möglichen maßnahme entschieden nämlich
zur einschränkung des bewegungsradius
auf 15 kilometer um den wohnort herum
sofern kein triftiger grund vorliegt
triftige gründe sind natürlich
arztbesuche oder arbeit
stetten die man aufsuchen muss
insbesondere haben wir hier im blick das
tages touristische ausflüge keinen
triftigen grund darstellen sie wissen
was in bestimmten regionen jetzt als es
geschneit hatte auch los war und wie
viele kontakte da entstanden sind
das muss verhindert werden einige
bundesländer praktizieren diese 15km
regel schon ist es also nicht etwas ganz
neues aber es kann und zu der radsport
strategien bei instanzen über 200
hinzutreten
wir haben uns noch einmal mit den
pflegeheimen befasst das ist ja bei
weitem nicht das erste mal die
testpflicht gibt es bereits sie gilt
schon einige zeit aber wir haben
festgestellt dass nicht überall diese
test anordnung auch schon ausreichend
durchgeführt werden dass es notwendig
ist personalaufstockung vorzunehmen und
hier sind wir sehr dankbar dass auch die
bundesagentur für arbeit solche extra
teams mit schulen wird um wirklich
sicher zu stellen vor ort das in allen
altenheimen diese test strategie
umfassend umgesetzt wird was die
erstattung der kosten anbelangt so haben
wir seit langem eine großzügige regelung
sowohl für die erstattung der tests als
auch für personalkosten die zusätzlich
notwendig sein werden und wir haben
jetzt noch einmal deutlich gemacht dass
auch einrichtungen der
eingliederungshilfe mit dieser
initiative erfasst werden sollen
wir sagen etwas zu der neuen mutation
des virus hier geht es vor allen dingen
darum dass die sequenzierung von viren
verstärkt wird in deutschland dazu wird
im rahmen des dritten bevölkerungsschutz
gesetzes eine zusätzliche verordnung
erlassen werden
wir haben uns sehr lange mit dem thema
impfens beschäftigt richtigerweise denn
wir wissen dass mit den nunmehr
verfügbaren impfstoffen ist eine
perspektive da es für eine
normalisierung unseres alltags und die
rückkehr zu einem leben ohne pandemie
beschränkte 1 man bedenke
einschränkungen und wir haben in diesem
zusammenhang
noch mal ausdrücklich klargestellt dass
bund und länder begrüßen dass es eine
gemeinsame impfstoff bestellung der
europäischen union gibt und dass das
ziel den wirkstoff gemeinsam für alle 27
länder der eu zu sichern
ein richtiges und wichtiges ziel ist im
übrigen auch ein ziel das im deutschen
interesse liegt denn wir sind umgeben
von vielen mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union wir arbeiten in einem
freien binnenmarkt wir haben einen
schengen raum in dem freie bewegung
möglich ist und eine hohe zahl von games
tten in deutschland kombiniert mit
vielen die nicht geimpft sind in unserer
nachbarschaft wird auch nicht zum wohle
deutschlands seien und deshalb wollen
wir keine nationalen alleingänge sondern
wir glauben dass der wirkungsvollste
gesundheitsschutz für uns durch eine
gemeinsames europäisches vorgehen auch
erreicht werden kann
wir haben in diesem zusammenhang noch
einmal geklärt was natürlich für das
terminmanagement extrem wichtig ist für
die länder
wann kann man voraussagen welche
lieferung bekommt wir haben im
augenblick nur eine zulassung eines
impfstoffs herstellers bei und ex kaiser
es werden andere dazu kommen wir wissen
allerdings nicht wann wie viele und
werden aber sicherstellen dass dann wenn
impfstoff auch da ist wirklich dieser
auch verimpft werden kann und das bedarf
natürlich eines höchstmaß an
berechenbarkeit ohne dass wir den
zulassungsbehörden in diesem fall der
europäischen zulassungsbehörde
vorgreifen können dass es natürlich auch
klar
haben sie eine ganze reihe von fragen
gestellt
wir werden im ersten quartal nur
priorisierte gruppen impfen können das
ist aber auch gar keine neue erkenntnis
wir werden im zweiten quartal nach
menschlichem ermessen und nach allem was
wir von den herstellern wissen deutlich
mehr impfdosen bereits haben und das
wird sich dann im 2
im zweiten quartal und im dritten
quartal natürlich noch einmal fortsetzen
insgesamt hat die europäische union
deutlich mehr impfstoff bestellt als
notwendig ist um alle menschen in der
europäischen union zu impfen
ein wichtiger punkt der betrieb von
kinderbetreuungseinrichtungen und
schulen
hier haben wir uns entschieden dass die
von den ländern ergriffenen maßnahmen
entsprechend dem beschluss vom 13
dezember bis ende januar verlängert
werden auch das wissen wir dass das eine
harte entscheidung ist aber wir halten
sie für notwendig weil es mit sich
bringt dass eltern auf ihre kinder auch
zu hause aufpassen müssen dass sie
selber betreuen müssen verlängern oder
wiederholen wir die regierung die wir
schon für das jahr 2020 hoffen dass
nämlich eltern je elternteil zehn
zusätzliche zu denen rechtlich schon
bestehende zehn tagen für die betreuung
von kindern bekommen das gilt
normalerweise wenn die kinder krank sind
den zweck erweitern wir wenn man die
panini pandemie bedingt der zugang zum
kinderbetreuungsangebot eingeschränktes
oder die präsenzpflicht im unterricht
ausgesetzt ist das heißt also dass
eltern die aus gründen einer wenn es
bedingten zugangs zu schulen oder
kindertagesstätten oder wegen
geschlossener schulen ihre kinder zu
hause betreuen müssen dann diese tage
die sonst nur für kranke kinder in
anspruch genommen werden können
auch in anspruch nehmen können und dass
diese tage auch verdoppelt werden
ja sagen noch etwas zu den finanziellen
kompensationen die natürlich mit
hochdruck gearbeitet werden weil wir
wissen was für geschlossene geschäfte
restaurants usw
die ausfälle bedeuten hier arbeiten bund
und länder eng zusammen und versuchen
die dinge soweit es möglich ist zu
beschleunigen und wir werden bei
einreisen aus risikogebieten eine
doppelte strategie einführen
das heißt man muss bei einreise einen
test vorweisen dann aber trotzdem in
quarantäne gehen und es kann sich dann
nach dem fünften tag wieder frei testen
lassen so wie das bis heute auch schon
ist das ist sehr wichtig wir hatten
jetzt wieder sehr großen reiseverkehr
über weihnachten und in diesem bereich
der offenen grenzen aber der sehr großen
risikogebiete um uns herum ist das
wichtig um den eintrag zu verringern
wir werden uns am 25 januar wieder
treffen um dann zu schauen wo wir stehen
die maßnahmen die wir heute beschlossen
haben sind einschneidend sie sind nicht
nur die fortsetzung dessen was wir vor
weihnachten getan haben sondern sie sind
angesichts der lage härter gerade was
kontakt beschränkungen anbelangt zum
teil auf was in hotspots
bewegungsmöglichkeiten anbelangt du hast
die schulen und kitas anbelangt die
fortsetzung ist auch eine große
herausforderung für eltern und die
kinder natürlich aber wir sehen uns dazu
genötigt um unser ziel nicht aus den
augen zu verlieren
ich habe immer wieder gesagt die
wintermonate sind das haben uns die
experten gestern noch einmal gesagt die
monate in denen die pandemie am
stärksten wüteten kann mit der
kombination des mutierten virus das auch
schon bei uns eingetragen wurde ist es
absolut notwendig und deshalb müssen wir
zu einem punkt kommen wo wir die
infektionsketten wieder nachvollziehen
können
denn ansonsten können wir immer nur nach
einer kurzen lockerung wieder
zurückgehen in einen lock down und um
das zu verhindern ist der versuch jetzt
wichtig wirklich noch mal deutlich
runter zu kommen
ja das war eine schwere
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz eine
konstruktive aber eine schwere ja nicht
glaube es ging vielen kolleginnen und
kollegen sowie mehr man ist doch hin und
hergerissen in dieser situation in der
wir uns befinden und beschäftigt sich
täglich mit der frage nicht nur wo
stehen wir an dieser in diesem
infektionsgeschehen sondern wie kann man
auch wieder eine perspektive ermöglichen
wie kann man die ersten schritte wieder
hin zu einer normalität gehen
das ist ja etwas was jeden tag in der
politik bundesweit eine rolle spielt
weil wir sehen wie umfassend auch diese
einschränkungen sind und wie belastend
ja auch für viele menschen gar keine
frage und wir haben auch viel erreicht
das muss man sagen ist das von allen
auch noch mal gewürdigt worden dass die
maßnahmen die miteinander formuliert
wurden im november im dezember dass die
entsprechende erfolge auch zeigen und
dass wir sehen wie die zahlen nach unten
gehen
sie gehen regional unterschiedlich stark
nach unten aber sie bewegen sich in
diese richtige richtung
man muss eben auch festhalten dass es
noch nicht reicht
die bundeskanzlerin hat eben schon
darauf aufmerksam gemacht dass sie ja
nicht nur gestern in der
expertenanhörung sondern auch durch
unser eigenes erleben wenn wir die
entsprechenden kliniken besuchen das wir
sehen wie die belastung in den
krankenhäusern ist insbesondere in den
intensiv medizinischen abteilungen und
wie das personal auch jeden tag
gefordert ist und tatsächlich an grenzen
kommt an grenzen der belastbarkeit auch
kommt also insofern war klar dass wir
obwohl wir eben viele erfolge schon
sehen und sehen dass wir auf dem
richtigen weg sind obwohl wir sehen dass
viele zahlen sich in die richtige
richtung bewegen jedoch noch deutlich
mehr zu tun haben und insofern war dann
auch klar dass das eine verlängerung der
beschlossenen maßnahmen bis zum 31
januar geben soll und das war auch im
kreis der ministerpräsidenten
ministerpräsidenten und strittig auch
dass es zu weiteren einschränkungen
kommt die sind nicht ohne
man muss das wirklich noch mal sagen das
was wir jetzt auch an zusätzlichen
kontakt beschränkungen beschlossen haben
dass wir insbesondere auch die maßnahmen
die iren nun weiter in den schulen
umgesetzt werden müssen dass wir sehen
dass dass das auch weiterhin belastungen
sind oder sogar zusätzliche belastungen
sind aber ihm dinge die doch nötig sind
um einen wirklich erfolgreichen weg im
laufe dieses jahres gehen zu können
gut ist dass wir jetzt in unserer
strategie eine zweite säule zur
bekämpfung dieser pandemie haben das ist
das thema impfen
es ist ein zweiter säule neben den
einschränkungen neben den maßnahmen die
bisher beschlossen wurden
und das ist eine zweite säule die mit
diesen einschränkungen ineinander
greifen muss das ist ganz klar
und insofern war das natürlich auch sehr
wichtig heute zu erfahren wie
verlässlich wie planbar sind die
nächsten lieferungen für januar februar
mindestens denn es hat ganz praktische
konsequenzen wenn wir wissen wann können
wir mit welchen impfstoffmengen rechnen
wissen wir auch wen er wann zu den
nächsten im termin einladen können wir
haben ganz konkret für berlin wir haben
so wie er das auch priorisiert das
bundesweit nach den menschen die erst in
den pflegeheimen jahr besucht werden und
geimpft werden haben wir die über
90-jährigen eingeladen jetzt gehen
gerade die briefe raus für die über
80-jährigen das sind schon alles
zehntausender größenordnung an briefen
an einladungen die jetzt ausgesprochen
werden zu den nächsten impftermin und
natürlich ist es dann wichtig den leuten
auch verlässliche termine nennen zu
können
und insofern war das heute den
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten sehr wichtig da auch
diese planungssicherheit zu bekommen für
die nächsten monate und wir wissen das
ja nun auch die kapazitäten aufwachsen
können mit zusätzlichen impfstoff von
anderen anbietern der in den nächsten
monaten mit dazu kommen kann also wir
sind gut vorbereitet in den ländern
das ist klar seit mitte dezember sind
die länder mit impfzentren und mobilen
teams vorbereitet wir haben hier
sprechenden terminvergaben koordiniert
wenn nun auch die impfstofflieferungen
verstetigt werden haben wir eben eine
weiteres ein weiteres standbein eine
weitere säule um gut auf krone reagieren
zu können neben unseren maßnahmen und
das ist auch wichtig dass wir mit beiden
maßnahmen reagieren so gut und richtig
alle einschränkungen auch in der
vergangenheit waren und ich sage es
nochmal so viel sie auch gebracht haben
so klar ist doch auch das erleben wir
jeden tag
es sind temporäre erfolge sind temporäre
erfolge und deswegen müssen wir mit dem
impfen einfach auch eine langfristige
perspektive reinbekommen um die menschen
dann tatsächlich auch zu entlasten und
wieder schritte in die normalität zu
ermöglichen und ich glaube wir haben in
diesem sinne jetzt auch große schritte
nach vorne gemacht hilfe mich
abschließend noch einmal sagen dass
trotz dieser ja nach wie vor auch
bedeutenden situationen ich sehe dass es
hier ein sehr klares und eindeutiges
commitment gibt der bundesländer und der
bundesländer mit dem bund in diesem
vorgehen
und ich glaube dass das auch sehr
wichtig ist das sehr wichtig ist das zu
spüren es mir gemeinsam wollen und
werden diese krisensituation bewältigen
und sie ist auch nur gemeinsam zu
bewältigen das ist immer wieder deutlich
geworden
es ist klar uns allen es ist jetzt auch
keiner zeit für halbherzigkeit weder bei
den beschlossenen maßnahmen jetzt
umzusetzen sind noch dann im rahmen
unserer impfstrategie ist jetzt die zeit
für halbherzigkeit wir müssen gerade
wenn wir unsere bisherigen erfolge nicht
und frage stellen wollen und nicht
wollen dass sie uns wegrutschen in den
nächsten wochen müssen wir diesen weg
auch entschlossen weiter gehen und ich
glaube das spüren auch viele menschen in
unserem land dass wir genau an dieser
entscheidenden stelle jetzt sind dass
wir jetzt auch durchhalten müssen in den
nächsten wochen mit diesen maßnahmen
beschlossen wurden damit wir dann
ergänzend zu den impfungen die zu
erleben sind dann auch wirklich eine ja
eine perspektive für die mitte des
jahres bekommen und dann wieder mehr
dinge zu ermöglichen im bereich der
kultur
das sport und viele andere dinge die uns
wichtig sind und unseren zusammenleben
also insofern glaube ich und dann noch
einmal anzuknüpfen
nach einem schweren tag und einer
schweren ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
kann man doch sagen eine sehr wichtige
und sehr erfolgreiche
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz auf unserem
weg diese pandemie zu bekämpfen herr
ministerpräsident
meine sehr verehrten damen dann ob es
eine ein schwerer tag war glaube ich
nicht aber es ist eine schwierige
situation für unser ganzes land und die
menschen nicht nur für deutschland
sondern europaweit wir spüren immer
wieder corona kommt immer wieder zurück
immer egal wer glaubt dass er cola
besiegt hat stellt fest dass wenn ein
stück weit zu schnell und vielleicht zu
unvorsichtig ist oder zu hoffnungsvoll
ist dass er eingeholt wird von den
herausforderung durch corona deswegen
ist glaube ich das heute ein sehr
ehrlicher tag und wir haben gestern eine
sehr wichtige und auch sehr nachhaltige
expertenrunde gehört die uns das noch
mal nach draußen geführt hat das was wir
heute tun folgt ausschließlich dem rad
in wissenschaftliche rat krone ernst zu
nehmen und darauf entsprechend zu
reagieren
es gibt so der grundkonzeption auch
keine bessere alternative international
da man sieht es an schweden überall dort
wo man versuchte einen anderen weg zu
gehen wird man dramatisch eingeholt und
deswegen ist die lage nach wie vor ernst
gibt leider keine möglichkeit zur
entwarnung
wir haben jetzt die situation dass die
zahlen nach wie vor sehr hoch sind
obwohl wir in den letzten tagen weniger
meldungen hatten weil es weniger test
gab eine gesundheitsämter haben weniger
gemeldet deswegen ist wahrscheinlich die
dunkelziffer relativ hoch so dass auch
das lka gesagt die herausforderung die
wir aus weihnachten silvester und in
reiserückkehrern haben müssen noch nicht
bislang abgebildet in den zahlen das
heißt sie müssen eher davon ausgehen
dass die zahlen wachsen und sind wir
bitte ehrlich vielen von uns geht es so
dass im namen der ersten welle wir
relativ wenig fälle im persönlichen
umfeld erlebt hat
aber es geht doch fast jeden von uns so
dass er viel erlebt im nahen umfeld im
beruflichen wie privaten bekanntenkreis
und häufig eben auch mit den schlimmsten
folgen
nämlich mit dem tod eines lieben
familienmitglieds deswegen glaube ich
einfach wäre es jetzt falsch frühzeitig
abzubrechen
hinzu kommt die wirklich große sorge um
ein mutiertes virus wenn es stimmt dass
motivieren sich in der regel durchsetzen
gegen die bisherigen werden also wie
aggressiveren wir dann könnte uns noch
einiges bevor stehen das beispiel
großbritannien zeigt ist dürfen wir auf
keinen fall unterschätzen wenn wir sie
diese risiken mit einander
gegenüberstellen dunkelziffer weil wir
nicht genau wissen was sich insbesondere
auf den reiseverkehr ergeben hat wenn
jetzt im zweiten feststellen dass ein
neues mutiertes virus sich
möglicherweise unterwegs befindet dann
ist die frage die reagieren wird darauf
und ich glaube das war die schwere
entscheidung vielleicht aber auch die
klarheit die dahintersteht
wir machen da keine experimente wir
setzen auf sicherheit das ist ganz
entscheidend
je weniger intensiv für einen locker
machen desto länger werde dauern und mit
der gefahr der weniger wirkung von die
intensive wir es machen desto besser
nachhaltiger könnte die wirkung in der
sein
das ist letztlich das motiv dass hinter
all diesen entscheidungen steht die wir
heute getroffen und deswegen im grunde
genommen die zweiteilung der lok tor
wird verlängert klar und er wird an
einigen stellen vertieft die fragen was
den kontakt radius und die
kontaktpersonen betrifft handelt die
zwei zentralen elemente aktive haben
nämlich mobilität auf der einen seite
und die kontakte die da sind das sind
die zwei zentralen parameter an denen
sich entscheidet wie stark oder die
abgeschwächt sich corona verbreiten kann
diese kontakte der einzelne hat und
welche mobilität sich entsprechend
bewegt insofern ist es keine keine
drangsalierung oder überzogen haid
sondern im gegenteil wir wissen dass das
alles für die menschen unglaublich
schwer ist und das ist die menschen
nervt und ich sag's auch persönlich es
nervt jeden einzelnen uns auch das macht
keinen spaß immer wieder sozusagen in
dem dauer chrome os zu sein
wir müssen in der verantwortung des
nicht bequemste sondern das
entscheidende tun von dem überzeugt sind
deswegen weiter kontakte
reduzieren deswegen bei der mobilität
reduzieren
in dem zusammenhang ist auch leider
schule und kita ab so sehr das ist eine
der schweren entscheidung weil wir
wissen wie wichtig das für eltern ist
die betreuung war für kinder unterricht
wichtig ist die lebendigkeit des treffen
von freunden aber bildung und die
bildungsabschlüsse in unserem land sind
trotzdem glaube ich ist es da
entscheiden dass wir die beschlüsse vom
dezember fortsetzen
und da auch sehr klar machen was haben
wir erlebt dass auch schule und auch
kita ein teil der verbreitung sein kann
aus anderen ländern bekommen die da
gerichte aus österreich dänemark aus
großbritannien dass gerade hier die
verbreitung des neuen virus vielleicht
eine zentrale rolle spielen könnte
deswegen auch da auch da ist es meiner
sicht klar die sicherheit der
schülerinnen schüler aber auch der
lehrer wäre steht jedenfalls als erster
punkt den es zu berücksichtigen gilt
deswegen werden wir aber in bayern wenn
ich das sagen darf
die maßnahme verlängern das heißt für
uns keine präsenz in schule und kita
dafür eben distanz unterricht und
entsprechende note betreuer
beides ist das was dann an der
entscheidenden stelle ist das heißt
distanz unterricht und notbetreuung als
möglicher ersatz was so ein bund heute
ein ganz wichtiges signal es ist dort wo
eltern in der betreuung erhebliche
probleme haben und ist nicht gelingt das
allein über die notbetreuung abzudecken
ist diese möglichkeit weitere
krankheitstage einzureichen bei vollem
lohnausgleich ein ganz starkes und
wichtiges angebot das heißt alle eltern
die keine notbetreuung finden und die
keine andere möglichkeit haben ihre
kinder zu betreuen haben dann ein
angebot selbst zu hause zu bleiben
bei den finanziellen ausgleich das ist
verbunden um eine wichtige zusage die
situation leicht wir bitten da wirklich
einfach um verständnis
noch ein satz zum impfen ich will doch
da müssen wir einfach ehrlich
miteinander sein
impfen ist hoffnung wir dürfen keine
falsche hoffnung ab
da ist vielleicht zu beginn der
infektion von dem einander zu viel
euphorie versprüht worden
impfen ist eine sensationelle
möglichkeit in der
kürze der zeit und ich glaube es ist
genügend gestellt worden
ich glaube dass der europäische weg
viele vorteile hat es wichtig dass
erneut so gesagt es ist aber auch nicht
verkehrt sich ins eigene land zu kümmern
also dass wir uns auch sorgen was in
deutschland passiert
im europäischen verbund ist heute noch
mal sehr klar geworden
vom fand ich dass heute auch sehr gut
dass die kanzlerin selbst sich mit
diesem thema so beschäftigt und es mit
zur chefsache gemacht hat und eben
einfach da voranzukommen
aber wir sprechen jetzt nicht zum
bestimmten stichtag gibt es genau schon
soviel dosen denn die wahrheit ist das
liegt natürlich in der hand auch der
hersteller die das entsprechend
produzieren weil mein eindruck ist wir
sind heute in der debatte ein großes
stück vorangekommen
letzter punkt ist damit am ersten
februar alles wieder gut ist damit alles
vorbei ich rate uns dringend keine
falschen hoffnungen zu wecken oder
versprechen zu machen
wir hoffen dass wir die situation wieder
deutlich verbessern können und dass wir
so gut wie möglich an die 50 oder
vielleicht unter die 50 kommen
die wahrheit ist dass in ländern wie
frankreich und spanien mit viel härteren
maßnahmen man die reduktion erreicht hat
fiel aber nicht so weit wie es nötig war
deswegen befürchte ich dass es für die
nächsten monate wir irgendwie mit diesem
virus weiter klug umgehen und lebens und
dass wir einen weg finden das zu
überwinden ich bin fest überzeugt im
laufe des jahres jeden wie corona
überwinden können mit den impfungen und
den möglichkeiten da bin ich fest von
überzeugt aber was wir jetzt brauchen
ist einfach nach wie vor die geduld die
rücksicht und das verständnis und das
bitte ich noch mal ausdrücklich und
bedanke mich sehr für unzählig viele
menschen die das machen
einige machen nicht somit für die gibt
es jetzt noch einige zusätzliche regeln
das sollen aber diejenigen die bislang
gut mitmachen nicht als bestrafung
empfinden sondern eigentlich nur als
ausgleich weil wir die vernünftigen ein
stück weit auch von den unvernünftigen
schützen wollen insofern ist der heutige
tag wieder ein wichtiger meilenstein
aber es ist sicher nicht der letzte in
der gesamten kolonie chronik die uns
dieses jahr noch beschäftigen wird
meine bitte an die journalisten bitte
beschreiben sie sicher
jeweils eine frage und dann geht es los
mit von dunst von handy noch einmal nach
der mutation fragen herr
ministerpräsident söder sie haben gerade
gesagt wenn das in deutschland ankommt
dann haben wir noch eine ganz andere
situation
ich würde gerne sie frau bundeskanzlerin
und auch die beiden ministerpräsidenten
fragen was das für eine situation wäre
und für war für wie wahrscheinlich
halten sie ist das deutsch das an
deutschland dieser kelch überhaupt
vorübergeht
das ist in gewisser weise ein wettlauf
mit der zeit wir haben gestern
insbesondere von professor thorsten
einige aussagen gehört es gibt keine
abschließende klarheit über die wirkung
dieses virus in seiner mutierten form
aber was man in england gesehen hat ist
dass es in den vergangenen wochen oder
sogar monaten ist ja wahrscheinlich
schon seit september in england
unterwegs dass es doch alle anderen
wären sorgten sehr verdrängt hat und
klar ist je weniger fallzahlen wir haben
umso besser können wir nach erfolgen und
umso weniger hat das neue mutierte virus
eine chance sich auszubreiten
deshalb ist es nicht ein neuer grund
aber ein grund mehr mit den incident
zahlen nochmal runter zu kommen die
alles was wir wissen ist zieht der
krankheitsverlauf nicht schwieriger aber
die verbreitungsgeschwindigkeit also die
frage bei wie viel kontakten hat das
virus eine chance über anderen sozusagen
zu einem anderen menschen zu gelangen
diese wahrscheinlichkeit wird ist erhöht
um wie viel wie gesagt das steht noch
nicht ganz klar fest aber wir sind ja
bisher vorsorglich agieren wir haben
einzelne fälle nachgewiesen in
deutschland ist ja bekannt und in der
presse gewesen
wie weit es sich ansonsten verleitet hat
wissen wir noch nicht und deshalb ja
auch diese
anstrengung jetzt stärker zu
sequenzieren also die genommen die
genome stärker zu analysieren als wir
das bisher in deutschland gemacht haben
das ist sowieso richtig und gut dass zu
tun die für eine präzisierung vornehmen
zu dem was sie erst gesagt habe
bezüglich der altenheime und den teams
sender zusammenstellen
die bundesagentur für arbeit wird die
vermittlung von personal unterstützen
die schulungen werden von den
hilfsorganisationen unternommen und die
kommunalen spitzenverbände werden
koordinieren also das nicht morgen bei
der bundesagentur für arbeit eine flut
von interessenten für schulung eingeht
das machen die hilfsorganisation
also muss noch mal zu sagen wir wissen
noch zu wenig über eine mögliche
mutation oder über die mutationen um
schon sagen zu können wie man dann
konkret darauf reagieren soll
wir wissen dass es da ist wir wissen
dass es auch bei uns angekommen ist wir
wissen nicht in welchem umfang wir
wissen nicht was es ganz konkret auslöst
an weiteren krankheitsverläufen und wie
man dann auch konkret darauf reagieren
soll dass es in der expertenanhörung
gestern ganz deutlich geworden aber es
ist völlig unstrittig
es löst weitere erkrankungen aus und
jede weitere erkrankung kann potenziell
auch eine schwere erkrankung sein und
damit eine zusätzliche belastung ganz
eindeutig und insofern müssen wir alles
tun um das möglichst zu vermeiden
aber auch ein kompletter lockdown weil
das ja dann immer mitschwingt muss man
jetzt alles richtig zu machen damit
möglichst niemand auch nur mit diesem
gefahrenpotenzial zu uns kommt ein
kompletter lockdown ist kein königsweg
und das an dieser stelle auch mal ganz
klar zu sagen
er spielt in dem zusammenhang eine rolle
und auch in vielen anderen diskussionen
wir haben beispiele dafür wir haben sie
in europa wir sehen jetzt gerade in
asien dass dort auch länder dies
vielleicht viel einfacher noch ihre
situation isolieren können als wir es in
deutschland können dass die jetzt auch
erhebliche rückschläge haben
es gibt bei dieser pandemie bekämpfung
nicht den einen königsweg schlichtweg
ausgeschlossen und aus die
runde auch ich weiß dass viele das so
nicht hören wollen aus diesem grunde bin
ich auch sehr davon überzeugt wie wir
gemeinsam in den letzten monaten um mit
der situation umgegangen seien dort
vorgegangen sind
wir haben immer sehr genau geguckt wie
die situation ist haben abgewogen was
ist der richtige schritt haben dinge
ermöglicht oder auch dinge eingeschränkt
je nachdem wie die situation war und wir
sind damit nicht schlecht gefahren
wir sind nicht schlechter gefahren als
europäische nachbarländer oder auch im
internationalen vergleich nicht schlecht
gefahren und das ihr jetzt wiederum mit
dieser zweiten möglichkeit neben den
maßnahmen mit der möglichkeit des lebens
nochmals zusätzlich reagieren können und
dass wir es wieder sehr abgewogen und
besonnen tun dass wir priorisieren dass
wir nacheinander die entsprechend
gefährdeten gruppen einladen ich glaube
dass das der richtige
und zum schluss auch wirklich
erfolgversprechenden weg ist ein
einfachen ein königsweg gibt es in
dieser pandemie bekämpfung nicht einsatz
noch mehr es muss ein büro logans sagen
in der in die biologie könnte es sein
dass mutierende werden die sich
schneller verbreiten sich am ende
durchsetzen werden
und wenn wir sehen was in einigen
ländern um uns herum passiert ist das
sehr optimistisch zu glauben dass es
nicht den stärkeren umfang bei uns
auftreten könnte
und insofern ist da vorsicht einfach der
beste weg es ist nicht ganz klar wie es
weitergehen wird
deswegen ist es einfach eine
entscheidungsgrundlage auch heute für
das noch mal sehr ernst zu nehmen das
ist auch die die lage jetzt nicht
antwort wir verlängern einfach weil die
zahlen jetzt noch zu hoch sind und das
kommt ihr noch eine neue sorge dazu die
nicht hundertprozentig klar einschätzbar
ist und aus diesen aus diesen
unterschiedlichen entscheidungen
erwägungen heraus ist einfach eine
vorsichtige strategie neben fall die
besser
dpa
frau bundeskanzlerin würden sie bitte
erläutern weil ich glaube viele die
einschränkungen der bewegungsfreiheit
interessiert was genau unter wohnort zu
verstehen ist die straße die wohnadresse
oder die stadt oder gemeinde zum
beispiel und warum ist man ausgerechnet
auf 15 kilometer gekommen und wenn sie
erlauben noch eine frage an den
ministerpräsidenten söder
nachdem im zusammenhang mit dem impfen
heftig kritisiert wird dass es da ein
durcheinander bei den einladungen gibt
warum hat man sich heute nicht
verständigt unter den ländern gemeinsam
zu sagen wir laden jetzt alle über 80
jährigen oder über 70-jährigen
schriftlich ein und jagen die nicht ins
internet
vielen dank wir haben das auch
ausführlich diskutiert weil in sachsen
das auch mit dem wohnbereich oder wie
das dorf benannt wurde geregelt ist aber
für eine stadt wie berlin macht es
glaube ich keinen sinn jetzt ab zu
zirkeln obmann von mitte noch bis
spandau darf oder bis kurz vorher das
heißt der wohnort ist als wohnort
gemeint in diesem zusammenhang die 15
kilometer da haben wir einfach anleihe
genommen bei dem was und die sachsen und
thüringer schon vereinzelt praktizieren
es geht im kern darum dass eben keine
touristischen tages reisen und freizeit
reisen unternommen werden an besonders
auch potenziell attraktive gebiete die
dann zu großen menschenansammlungen
führen obwohl gar keine verabredung
stattgefunden hat dass es der
hintergrund und das werden dann die
länder auch in der jeweiligen situation
sehr verantwortungsvoll entscheiden
ja ich habe es doch gesagt wenn sie
mitte wurden sind der wohnort ist berlin
und wir fangen nicht an jetzt innerhalb
von berlin den weg abzumessen von mitte
nach spannender oder marzahn und dann
kurz vor stadtbezirks grenze das halten
wir nicht für praktikabel und deshalb
ist also die bewegung in berlin erlaubt
zum beispiel reiz passfoto
bei den 15 kilometern haben wir uns wie
gesagt auch in sachsen und thüringen und
an den erfahrungen orientiert und mit
wir gehen einfach davon aus und so wird
uns das ja auch von dort bestätigt dass
man innerhalb dieses radius das was man
eben für den täglichen bedarf auch
erledigen muss auch erledigen kann
ob es eben der arztbesuche oder die
einkäufer die für den täglich mit auch
wichtig sind und das entsprechend
private umfeld dass ich das in diesem
radius bewegt insofern haben wir da
tatsächlich von den erfahrungen aus
sachsen und thüringen gelernt wir haben
uns deshalb das war ihre zweite frage
nicht auf eine einheitliche einladungs
system verständigt weil die länder jetzt
schon mit ihren systemen arbeiten wie in
berlin arbeiten ebenso wie sie es
ansprechen mit diesem schriftlichen
einladungs systemen gruppe für gruppe
werden die menschen eingeladen und
können dann die termine verabreden
andere haben schon die entsprechenden
plattformen im internet dafür frei
geschaltet und sind dort in der
terminvergabe das wieder in die ein oder
andere richtung umzustellen erschien uns
einfach nicht klug kann dessen ergänzen
es gibt unterschiedliche strukturen
wären bei einer fast 100 impfzentren
also 99
andere länder haben weniger impfzentren
machen das zentrale bei uns wird es für
die kommunen organisiert
wir liegen mit dem was gerade für impft
wird sehr gut und er wird es auch so
gemacht da waren auch briefe
rausgeschickt aber die kommunale
struktur die föderale hilft da er weil
es ja für den einzelnen wichtig ist was
er vor ort erfährt und jetzt nicht wie
ein reines bundesweites verfahren ist
das glaube ich läuft jetzt ganz gutes
problem ist beim im film meiner meinung
nach nicht wie die struktur ist die
infrastruktur soll im 1
wann der nächste impfstoff gruppe haben
heute besprochen und dann kann es auch
verhindert werden dass wir noch ein
bisschen gedanken nach die celtics das
thema impfbereitschaft denn wir sind ja
jetzt dabei in den pflegeheimen auch zu
impfen
und es ist nicht so dass die impfquote
dort extrem hoch ist und rückmeldung die
ich bei uns hat aus bayern
das ist da sehr differenzierte
ergebnisse gibt es sowohl bei den
bewohnern die dort sind als auch bei den
pflegekräften in so sein dann wäre auch
noch mal nicht nur für mehr impfstoff
trommeln müssen sondern auch für die
bereitschaft diesen impfstoff danach
abzunehmen
das wird auch noch spannende debatten
geben die außen als kanzlerin
im beschluss steht er jetzt wieder ein
appell an die arbeitgeber auf mobiles
arbeiten zu setzen
was macht es denn so schwer sich in der
runde darauf zu einigen dass menschen
die mobil arbeiten können erst dann auch
grundsätzlich tun und vielleicht
begründen müssen warum sie es nicht
machen
wir wollen jetzt nun für diese
beschränkte zeit nicht einen riesen
neuen verfahrensweg einführen sondern
wir setzen hier wirklich auf die
bereitschaft vieler das gibt's ja auch
home office zu ermöglichen wo immer das
ist und die umkehrung zu der haben wir
uns noch nicht entschieden weil wir auch
viele gute beispiele sehen das
unternehmen und betriebe und behörden
ich weiß das ja für uns selbst hier home
office auch breit anbieten wobei haring
wolters da draußen
bundeskanzler neben wurde gewarnt dass
keine falschen erwartungen oder
hoffnungen geweckt werden dürfen wie es
mit der produktion der impf kapazitäten
jetzt steht in den beschluss drinnen
dass der bund sich nochmal mit den
herstellern zusammensetzt wie will er
denn erreichen dass die produktion
wirklich ausgebaut wird wird das auch
mit staatlichen mitteln sein so wie es
ja auch bei der massenproduktion oder
anderen teilen der fall war und herr
söder glauben sie eine kurze nachfrage
zu dem was sie vorher gesagt haben mit
der mutation heißt das nicht auch dass
man in den grenzgebieten ganz anders
vorgehen muss weil wir gesehen haben in
der zweiten welle das vor allem sachsen
und bayern stark betroffen waren in den
grenzgebieten wo die infektionszahlen
hochgehen und sich dann weiter
ausgebreitet haben also wenn die
erwartungen zu dämpfen will ich noch mal
folgendes sagen es ist ja wirklich eine
sehr sehr gute nachricht dass wir
weniger als ein jahr nach ausbruch der
pandemie bei uns bereits einen im
schloss zugelassen haben
das hat es in der geschwindigkeit
überhaupt noch nicht gegeben und das
drei tage nach zulassung oder besser
gesagt fünf tage nach zulassung
dazwischen war noch weihnachtsfeiertage
oder 23 27 also vier tagen hat
zulassungen bereits die ersten impfungen
stattfinden können das als heißt das
schon produziertes material da war das
alles ist nur mit völlig neuem ablauf
von genehmigungsverfahren und ähnlichem
gegangen vielleicht ist manchmal dadurch
die erwartung erzielt worden ist sei
schon so viel impfstoff da wie wir jetzt
brauchen und es seien nur noch die frage
wie käfer impfen können wir das ist im
augenblick und im ersten quartal noch
nicht so das wird sich ändern im zweiten
quartal wenn die genehmigung erteilt
werden wie wir das jetzt auch
voraussehen aber wir stecken nicht in
den herstellern das ist ja klar wir
wissen zum beispiel nicht wann bekommt
astrazeneca die genehmigung der
europäischen behörde
wann wird qurec so weit sein wann werden
johnson & johnson so weit sein man kann
übersehen dass sie in den studien schon
relativ fortgeschritten sind und dass es
aussichten gibt dass wir dann im zweiten
quartal sehr viel mehr impfstoff auch
zur verfügung haben werden
als im ersten quartal die frage wie
können wir das unterstützen
da haben die hersteller insbesondere
auch der herr schaar ihn ja immer wieder
darauf hingewiesen dass das ja jetzt
keine einfache produktion ist dazu
braucht man reinräume dazu braucht man
anlagen die schon sozusagen auf
bestimmte impfstoffe gleich sind die
müssen umgebaut werden
und da ist es ein glücklicher zufall
dass wir so eine anlage in marburg haben
wo die genehmigungen auch weit
fortgeschritten sind und wo es eine
berechtigte hoffnung gibt dass dann auch
die produktion bereits ende februar oder
märz starten kann
das würde für beyoncé kaiser noch mal
die möglichkeiten zu produzieren sehr
stark erhöhen
wir wollen seitens der bundesregierung
mit den herstellern besprechen ob sie
andere orte sehen an denen auch dieses
wieder möglich sein würde und wo wir
natürlich mit aller kraft von
länderseite hier von bundesseite her
unterstützen würden ich glaube die frage
der finanzen ist für die die jetzt einen
impfstoff haben im augenblick nicht die
kernfrage weil dass man davon ausgehen
kann dass damit ja sozusagen ein
geschäftsmodell erfolgreich ist sollten
aber darlehen notwendig sein oder
überbrückungsfinanzierung wir haben bei
uns geholfen wir haben schon weg
geholfen das wird nicht das thema sein
die eu hat geholfen
also daran sollte und wird das nicht
scheitern das ist trotzdem eine andere
ausgangslage als die meisten produktion
wo wir ja sozusagen etwas lernen müssen
herzustellen hier haben menschen und
unternehmen glücklicherweise durch ja
und jahrzehntelange forschung schon die
vorarbeiten getroffen und insofern
werden wir die lage beobachten ist soll
jedenfalls an keinerlei staatliche
aktivität scheitern
das schnell weiterer impfstoff
produziert werden kann
zwei bemerkung die einen eher gehen zum
frühen wechsel aber es gibt einen vollen
ausgleich filius kinderkrankengeld es
verlängert wird das sind die massnahmen
des bundes deswegen wollte ich dann noch
mal darauf hinweist dass sind glaube ich
70 prozent
dass das auch dann klar ist unter
falscher zungenschlag ist aber das
zweite mit der grenze das macht uns
große sorgen einmalig von bayerischer
seite wie einige andere grenze länder
seit längerer zeit auf das problem
hingewiesen
es steht jetzt ihren beschluss bin dass
dazu eine testpflicht kommen soll
das ist gut und sicher auch aber
theoretisch hätte man das schon eher
machen können weil gerade meint sehr
viele jetzt bereits auf der rückreise
sind wir haben es inter gemacht
eine doppelte testpflicht bei 1 30 und 1
vermittelt war danach weil es natürlich
ein großes risiko ist wir haben viele
großartige menschen die bei uns leben
und arbeiten familien heimkehrer die
jetzt zurückkommen und aus ländern in
denen man es einmal nicht so strenge
corona regeln hat und lebt wie bei uns
und da ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
wieder möglicherweise noch eine
herausforderung gekommen er relativ hoch
das hat übrigens auch schon gegeben nach
dem sommer wann genau die
herausforderung
und deswegen ist das jetzt gut dass das
auf bundesebene vereinbart wurde
wir haben sie in bayern schon vorgemacht
wir haben allein in den letzten tagen
soll das bayerische innenministerium
über den bayerischen grenzpolizei und
mit übungs großartiger unterstützung der
bundespolizei allein 1300 fälle entdeckt
wo es dann über weiße und die
gesundheitsbehörden gab wo es eine
nachfolge geben muss also das heißt das
thema ist hoch bei rowland insofern ist
es gut dass wir da jetzt entsprechende
maßnahmen gemeinschaftlich treffen wie
gesagt ist hätte man auch vielleicht
noch ein paar tage eher machen können
aber es ist gut dass es jetzt auch
verstärkt kontrollieren auf den routen
wie notwendig sind letzte frage herr
delfs bloomberg frau bundeskanzlerin
es gab in den letzten tagen berichte
wonach sie den gesundheitsministerien
gesundheitsmesse gedrängt haben sollen
die verantwortung für die impfstoff
beschaffung an an die eu kommission zu
übertragen hatten sie auch eben noch mal
betont als beleg wurde heute ein
entsprechender brief in diesem medium
abgedruckt genießt ersparen noch ihr
volles vertrauen als minister oder ist
die tatsache dass sie die impfstoff
beschaffung zur chefsache machen wollen
ein beweis ihres misstrauens nein es ist
so gewesen dass wir in einem ständigen
und sehr intensiven austausch war nicht
sehr begrüßt dass jetzt sparen dann auch
im blick auf die deutsche
ratspräsidentschaft zusammen mit seinen
kollegen aus frankreich und italien und
den niederlanden vier europäische länder
die selber hersteller auch haben
und/oder produzierende werke haben
da haben sich zusammengeschlossen haben
gesagt das hat keinen sinn wenn wir alle
einzeln mit denen herstellern verhandeln
sondern wir wollen das gemeinsam tun das
ist dann im gesundheits minister rat
diskutiert worden und es hat sich
gezeigt dass alle mitgliedstaaten daran
interesse hatten und da lag es nahe dass
dann in die verantwortung der kommission
zu stellen zumal die auch eine ganze
reihe von finanziellen mitteln zur
verfügung hatte um dieser passt also
diese etwa des purchase agreements mit
denen herstellern zu verhandeln
und das ist ein prozess gewesen den ich
positiv begleitet habe ich habe den
bundesgesundheitsminister in jeder phase
hier unterstützt und finde das vorgehen
sehr richtig und ohne die hilfe auch aus
den nationalstaaten hätte vielleicht die
kommission nicht so gut und ohne die
kommission hätten die nationalstaaten
alleine nicht so gut verhandeln können
ich glaube das ist ein prozess gewesen
der unter dem strich richtig war
natürlich kann die kommission in diesem
zusammenhang immer nur auch das
verhandeln was von den mitgliedstaaten
gewünscht wird und die kommission hat
sich darauf ausgerichtet wie auch
die deutsche position es war mit allen
voraussichtlichen herstellern gespräche
zu führen und auch entsprechende
abkommen abzuschließen und dann gab es
aber durchaus unterschiedliche
situationen auch in den einzelnen
mitgliedsstaaten wie man impfstoffe
bestellen wollte welchen man den vorrang
gegeben hat sie werden sich erinnern
dass gab mal eine zeit da hat sah so aus
als ob astrazeneca der impfstoff ist der
die erste zulassung bekommen wird das
hat sich dann nicht bewahrheitete
und deutschland hat dann immer die
position eingenommen auch das habe ich
beim bundesgesundheitsminister sehr
unterstützt das wenn nicht alle länder
von einer bestimmten summe ihren anteil
wollten der bevölkerung zu steht dass
dann die bundesregierung gesagt hat dann
übernehmen wir für deutschland den rest
und es hat sich dann gerade bei dem
hersteller bei und eckpfeiler der erst
gar nicht so umworben war in der
europäischen union herausgestellt dass
in dem moment als die daten so sehr gut
waren natürlich mehr mitgliedstaaten
gesagt haben okay dann beteiligen wir
uns auch das hat dazu geführt dass wir
etwas weniger dosen bekommen haben
nämlich nur das was uns zusteht so und
das ist glaube ich ein vorgang gewesen
der absolut richtig war und der uni
entspannt so gar nicht stattgefunden
hätte aber auch die kommission hat sich
hier sehr ins zeug gelegt und insofern
stellt sich schon die frage überhaupt
gar nicht sondern sparen macht einen
prima job jetzt in den gesamten tagen
und es sozusagen auf verschiedensten
gebieten es geht ja hier vom dritten
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz bis zu
gesprächen mit den herstellerfirmen und
vielen rechtlichen fragen werden heute
die frage 56 soßen wie ist das mit dem
bauerntag impfstoff und ich kann da nur
froh sein dass der gesundheitsminister
so aktiv ist
dann denke ich wie schön
soweit also die pressekonferenz von
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel die jetzt
gerade noch kroner konform ihrer maske
aufsetzt und den ministerpräsidenten der
bundesländer zu ihren beratungen heute
und den neuen beschlüssen zur bekämpfung
der korona pandemie und darüber wollen
wir jetzt gleich sprechen mit meiner
kollegin nicole diekmann im
hauptstadtstudio außerdem ist bei mir im
studio zu gast günther neufeld von der
redaktion recht und justiz da werden wir
gleich über die rechtlichen fragen
sprechen und später im stream dann noch
professor thomas lehr er ist professor
für klinische pharmazie an der uni des
saarlandes das heißt da möchten wir noch
mal auf die wissenschaft gucken wir
fangen jetzt aber mal an
bei nicole diekmann im hauptstadtstudio
berlin zu den politischen beschlüssen
nicole was war denn jetzt so ja die
größte überraschung bei dem was gerade
verkündet wurde
für mich persönlich die inhaltlich
größte überraschung war dieser radius
der jetzt 15 km betragen soll soweit der
inzidenz wert in einem landkreis die 200
übersteigt also 200 infizierte auf
hunderttausend einwohner innen innerhalb
von sieben wochen das war vor allem vom
honorar wurde heute morgen in einem sehr
ehrlichen und in teilen auch sehr
verzweifelten interview schon mal sehr
konkret ins gespräch gebracht worden im
deutschlandfunk ich hatte da so ein
bisschen meine zweifel ob sich das
wirklich durchsetzt aber anscheinend war
das gar nicht mal so eine lange
diskussion also da waren sich ja eben
alle drei in dieser pressekonferenz
einig dass das schon in weiten teilen
große übereinstimmungen heute gegeben
hat und gute zusammenarbeit zwischen
bund und ländern
was mich vom ton her sehr überrascht hat
war das der anfänglich im raum
befindliche elefant nämlich ihren spaß
an der bundesgesundheitsminister zum
schluss so explizit hier angesprochen
worden ist es gab in den vergangenen
tagen ja massive kritik von einem teil
der presse aber auch vom
koalitionspartner der spd an ihren
sparen stichwort impfdosen bestellung
und da hat man jetzt eben gesehen also
die kanzlerin hat ihm gerade noch mal
ganz klar in schutz genommen
wohingegen sich bayerns
ministerpräsident markus söder nicht
verkneifen konnte davon zu reden
die kanzlerin habe jetzt thema impfen
jetzt zur chefsache gemacht
das war klarer seitenhieb daraufhin
sparen aber die angriffe auf den spann
kam ja auch vom koalitionspartner von
der spd die cdu soll da von einer
konzertierten aktion zur verhinderung zu
einer möglichen kanzlerkandidatur
geredet haben geht es tatsächlich jetzt
schon so weit dass man da bis zum ende
des jahres guckt um das jetzt zu nutzen
was gerade passiert
na ja es ist natürlich für beide seiten
eine gute gelegenheit dass 2021 ein
superreicher ist inklusive einer
bundestagswahl
also das ist natürlich eine vorlage für
die spd die die möglichst gut
abschneiden will bei so nah war das geht
allen parteien so es ist aber auch dann
wiederum eine gute gelegenheit von
seiten der cdu das eben als
wahlkampfmanöver oder eben als manöver
um eine kanzlerschaft von ihren sparen
der im übrigen sicher gar nicht bewirbt
um den cdu-vorsitz bisher jedenfalls der
ja womöglich eine voraussetzung wäre für
eine kanzlerkandidatur
also man weiß es nicht genau es ist
natürlich es liegt nahe zu sagen es ist
ein wahlkampfmanöver der spd muss es
aber nicht sein aber es ist natürlich
dann einfach zusagen von seiten der cdu
aus deren reihen der kritisierte
minister ja kommt dann zu sagen na ja es
geht ja nur um die stimmen der wähler
innen und damit von
halten ab so lenken von möglicherweise
angebrachter kritik dann wollen wir uns
jetzt mal mit den inhalten beschäftigen
die gerade beschlossen wurden mein
kollege an seinem stern hat das mal ganz
kurz für uns zusammengefasst was dort
gerade verkündet wurde
alle bestehenden anti virus maßnahmen
werden bis zum 31 januar verlängert
gastronomie und einzelhandel bleiben
also bis dahin geschlossen genau wie
schulen und auch kitas zusätzlich werden
die kontakt beschränkungen noch einmal
verschärft privat darf man nur noch eine
weitere person treffen die nicht aus dem
eigenen haushalt kommt und in regionen
mit mehr als 200 neuinfektionen pro
100000 einwohner in sieben tagen wird
die bewegungsfreiheit eingeschränkt ohne
einen sogenannten triftigen grund darf
man dann maximal 15 kilometer weg vom
eigenen zuhause so und zu diesen
maßnahmen gibt es viele fragen hier bei
uns im stream eine der meistgestellten
ist tatsächlich ab wann gilt denn diese
verschärfung ab sofort oder
ab nächste woche ich hab da nichts zu
gefunden dass das aufgefallen ist eine
frage die ich mir selber auch stelle ich
würde sagen
aus der erfahrung heraus geben sich die
länder ja normalerweise immer zwei drei
tage vorlauf damit sich alle darauf
einstellen können
bisher war aber dann auch wiederum das
argument die wirtschaft muss sich darauf
einstellen die restaurants und cafés
müssen sich darauf einstellen die müssen
sich im moment auch gar nichts neues
einstellen die bleibt er weiterhin
geschlossen also langer rede kurzer sinn
das geht weder aus dem papier hervor das
hier heute kursiert ist noch aus der
pressekonferenz gerade nur gelten diese
maßnahmen die jetzt gerade eben
verkündet worden sind ja erst mal nur
bis zum 31
januar werden heute in fünfter sind 26
tage also man wird wahrscheinlich sehr
schnell zu diesen maßnahmen greifen wenn
sie dann auch werden sollen
ein großer wichtiger punkt für viele
zuschauer ist natürlich die frage nach
den schulen und kitas was passiert dabei
gab es ja auch viel hin und her die
kultusminister haben sich gestern
zusammengesetzt sind nicht so richtig
auf eine klare linie gekommen jetzt
findet sich in dem papier eigentlich nur
ein wir machen weiter so wie bisher
was heißt das konkret ja genau das was
du gerade gesagt hast daniel ziemlich
viel um konkretes ist bleibt jetzt
erstmal bei dem status quo der im moment
fährt bzw in den ländern in denen noch
herbst in denen noch ferien sind
natürlich nicht erst also die schulen
bleiben zu man setzt jetzt auf markus
söder hat es gerade gesagt er solche
pressekonferenzen ja auch immer nutzt
als bayerischer ministerpräsident um
sich zu profilieren
also er sagt er bei uns in bayern setzen
wir auf hybrid unterricht das bedeutet
also oder eben auf auf fernunterricht
das bedeutet also man setzt auf digitale
lösung der von schule zu schule er
variabel gut ausgeprägt sind
aber de facto bleiben die schulen und
die kitas auch zu bis auf notbetreuung
was man ja auch sagen muss ist bei
diesen drei stufen modell das die
kultusminister in den gestern vorgelegt
haben also erst eine öffnung der klassen
eins bis sechs später dann die
weiterführenden klassen hybrid
unterricht und dann wieder die schulen
in der dritten stufe ganz auf da fehlte
ja was ganz entscheidend ist nämlich
eine inzidenz es gab keine vorgaben ab
wann greift welche stufe ab welcher
inzidenz zahlt kann man weiter locker in
die schulen wieder öffnen
also auch da war man gestern mit dem was
man vorgelegt hat relativ schwammig aber
diese stufen modell scheint er jetzt
erstmal vom tisch zu sein es wird
einfach weiter gemacht die bis jetzt
waren ja auch sagen muss die politik hat
sich das relativ einfach gemacht und hat
nicht wie bei dem ersten walk down
letztes jahr anfang des jahres gesagt
okay es gelten
nur noch es können nur noch menschen
ihre kinder in die schule schicken die
in systemrelevanten berufen arbeiten
es wurde ja gesagt eltern sollten das
selber entscheiden oder das ist ja jetzt
geht dann doch jetzt weiterhin das heißt
die notbetreuung kann im endeffekt jeder
oder jede für sich in anspruch nehmen
also damit dass ich wie du macht die
politik es sich leicht und schiebt die
verantwortung den eltern so die entweder
ein schlechtes gewissen haben weil sie
ihre kinder nicht in die schule schicken
weil es ist eine abwägung zwischen
infektionsrisiko und was verpassen die
kinder nicht nur an unterrichtsstoff
sondern auch an sozialen miteinander an
sozialisation an kontakten zu anderen
auch zu lehrer innen aber also entweder
hat man deswegen schlechtes gewissen
weil man die kinder nicht schick oder
man schickt die kinder und hat deswegen
eben schlechtes gewissen weil man sie
einem erhöhten infektionsrisiko
aussetzten
so jetzt haben wir einmal auch mal diese
kontakt beschränkungen die verkündet
wurden das heißt verschärft von fünf
personen aus zwei haushalten auf jetzt
nur noch eine person aus einem anderen
haushalt viele user innen fragen hier
fallen auch ein kinder für diese einen
personen regel ich nenne es mal
exemplarisch michael der sich per mail
bei uns gemeldet hat können sie und
könnt ihr übrigens weiterhin tun z
erfreute - live at zdf.de ist die
adresse
da kann auch eine mail schicken falls
sie oder ihr gerade in unserer zdf heute
app zuguckt alle anderen wirte gerne
weiter die kommentarspalten nutzen also
nicole weiß oder was ob das mit den
kindern jetzt auch gilt kann man quasi
mit einer anderen person und drei
kindern jemanden besuchen
also wenn man jetzt strengt sich an dem
papier orientiert und an der
pressekonferenz dann fein kinder nicht
unter diese regel also das heißt kinder
sind von dieser regelung nicht
ausgenommen die gilt auch für kinder das
bedeutet wenn ich mit meiner familie mit
meinem mann mit meinen beinen
zusammen wolle dürfen wir noch ein
weiteres kind zum beispiel zum spiel zu
uns einladen aber dessen mutter oder
dessen vater darf nicht mit zu uns
reinkommen
aber auch da gilt es ist einigermaßen
schwierig denn es ist auch nicht
explizit ausgeschlossen
es sind auch das ist noch fragezeichen
an diesem abend die user fragen was mit
zwei paaren ist die in zwei haus ständen
leben das werden dann ja vier personen
aus zwei ausständen das heißt das würde
dann tatsächlich diese regel nicht mehr
erlauben
andere frage ist was es mit den
beschränkungen beisetzungen wie viele
personen dürfen dabei sein bei der alten
regelung waren es 20 personen
das müsste ja eigentlich so weiter
gelten die bisher also habe ich das auch
verstanden
also wir sehen hier viel unsicherheiten
bei unseren zuschauerinnen was die neuen
regeln angeht tatsächlich hat unsere
korrespondentin grad schon festgestellt
es gibt viele schwammige formulierungen
auch was die bewegungs beschränkungen
angeht da gelten ja jetzt die regeln
dass man sich noch mal selber mal gucken
und dann die koalition nochmals waren
das war die inzidenz 100 ab einer
distanz von 100 bei je 200.000
einwohnern in der beide in trogen 200
geblieben genau 201 200 mehr als meine
güte 200 neue infektionen 100 800.000
einwohner innen binnen sieben tagen rund
200 genau ich bin durcheinander gekommen
wir haben viele zahlen in den ganzen tag
über gehört und das war mal auch
tatsächlich von einer instanz von 104
rede
wir können das man ganz gut denn
angucken ich habe hier mal auf meinem
laptop unsere interaktive karte auf
unserer zdf heute seite aufgerufen da
kann man einfach mal mit der maus
darüber fahre dann sieht man zum
beispiel hier der oder spree landkreis
in brandenburg wäre definitiv betroffen
mit 245 fällen je 100.000 einwohner in
den letzten sieben tagen oder auch ja
quasi diese ganze region bautzen
landkreis in sachsen görlitz also fast
in ganz sachsen gilt das dann aber auch
in thüringen saalfeld rudolstadt aber
auch wir sehen unten die im grunde alle
dunklen landkreise hier freyung grafenau
in bayern oder deggendorf in bayern
wären alle betroffen
das heißt
das sind dann doch relativ viele
landkreise ist glaub das lka hat von gut
70 gesprochen die jetzt erst mal davon
betroffen wären sie da 70 geld da gibt
es ziemlich viele fragen mit die
cleverste fand ich weiß nicht ob wir die
beantworten können
wenn ich in einem landkreis wurde der
unter 200 instanzen hat und in einen
landkreis fahren möchte der über 200 hat
oder durch wahren möchte darf ich das
dann also tatsächlich merke ich einfach
unsere zuschauer beschäftigen sich
wirklich detailliert mit diesen neuen
regelungen und stellen solche fragen
fällt die antwort dazu ein die jetzt bei
spontan nicht es geht ja um die 15
kilometer die man sich von seinem
eigenen ort entfernen darf es also
erstmal braucht man einen triftigen
grund
ja das ist mal die erste wichtige der
erste wichtige punkt den man klären muss
ein triftiger grund ist zum beispiel ein
arztbesuch oder der besuch bei der
arbeit so denn wenn dieser grund
vorliegt und man muss zum arzt fahren es
geht ja nicht darum dass man nicht in
diese kreise rhein fahren darf es geht
darum ach so jetzt verstehe ich die
frage erst okay ich bin auch noch mitten
im prozess also das heißt ich wohne in
einer hunderttausend oder hunderter in
incidents region und will in eine 200
inzidenz region genau und ist das dann
erlaubt also es ist tatsächlich eine
sehr interessante frage
vielleicht kannst du zum abschluss als
letztes zusammenfassung tatsächlich
diese bewegungs beschränkung nochmals
zusammen fassen weil das wurde ja auch
nachgefragt gerade auf der
pressekonferenz
weil es unklarheit gab was jetzt
eigentlich als wohnort mit was damit
gemeint ist ne also wohnort also dem
angela merkel machte das ein bisschen
ungeduldig deutlich am beispiel berlin
gesagt wenn sie in berlin mitte wohnen
und sie wollen jetzt nach berlin
spannender dann fangen wir jetzt nicht
an zwischen mitte und spandauer die
kilometerzahl abzumessen ihr wohnort ist
berlin
das heißt also überschreitet berlin
wahrscheinlich dann als ganzes wenn man
so argumentiert die inzidenz von 200
dann darf ich mich als berlinerin ich
wohne zum beispiel in prenzlau
berg darf ich mich 15 kilometer von
prenzlauer berg weit entfernen aber
nicht weiter als 50 kilometer gemessen
ab der stadtgrenze von berlin
darüber hinaus das heißt als dass man
isst man sich das verständlich erklären
ich glaube schon aber als dienerin hat
man glaube ich tatsächlich dann den
vorteil dass es einen relativ großen
radius das wo man sich bewegen darf
quasi du darfst dich in ganz berlin
bewegen aber nicht weiter als die
stadtgrenze wenn man in einem relativ
kleinen radius wohnt dann hat man mehr
pech gehabt
nicole vielen dank jetzt erstmal für die
beantwortung dieser fragen und für die
einschätzungen und sie sehen hier bei
mir schon günther neufeld im studio aus
unserer redaktion recht und justiz war
grase diese bewegungseinschränkung sind
neu in deutschland zumindest in den
meisten bundesländern in sachsen gilt es
ja schon ein bisschen länger
jetzt soll das für die ganze
bundesrepublik gelten das ist ja doch
schon relativ schwerer eingriff in
unsere grundrechte oder über die ganze
bundesrepublik nur dort wo wir die
inzidenz von mehr als 200 haben ja
wissen schwerer eingriff in die
grundrechte wird deswegen von juristen
auch kritisch diskutiert gibt es sehr
verschiedene meinungen
denn jeder eingriff in ein grundrecht
braucht ja eine rechtfertigung das kann
man nicht einfach so machen das muss
verfassungsmäßig abgesichert sein da
gibt es grundsätze zum beispiel heißt es
so ein eingriff muss geeignet
erforderlich und angemessen sein und da
gibt es schon einige juristen die sagen
naja geeignet also wenn ich mich im
umkreis von 15 kilometer bewegen das
darf ich ja und dort viele viele
menschen treffe 100 oder mehr dann kann
ich mich natürlich vielfach anstecken
oder auch angesteckt werden oder andere
anstecken
andererseits gibt es auch den fall eine
überschreitet diese 50 kilometer grenze
fährt also 20 30 40 50 kilometer weit um
zb in der wohnung seiner freundin sehr
zurückgezogen zu leben und mit ihr
einsam im wald spazieren zu gehen
dann wird er durch das überschreiten
dieser grenze
die ansteckungsgefahr nicht erhöht das
heißt darstellen schon einige sehr
kritische fragen ob das denn wirklich
geeignet ist
allerdings sei auch das zu sagen es gibt
wie du schon sagst diese regelung ist
sachsen
und es gibt ja sagt nach einem
gerichtsurteil vom sächsischen
oberverwaltungsgericht ein 1 1 1 1
antrag ist abgelehnt worden dagegen und
das gericht hat gesagt nee das ist
soweit okay das kommt immer darauf an
wie dann die einzelnen gerichte und
richter das betrachten es gibt ja auch
an und die sagen was ist der sinn dieser
regelung aktuell ist es der vor allen
dingen der sind diese zusammenballung
und von menschen in wintersportgebieten
zu unterbinden im harz im sauerland den
schwarzwald aber das alles gesehen wie
sich da alle auf den schneebedeckten
hängen und pisten schön versammelt haben
und wenn einem dann nichts besseres
einfällt als diese regel um das zu
unterbinden
dann wird auch wie vielleicht der ein
oder andere richter sagen diese regel
ist verfassungsgemäß also es gibt
darüber noch keine höheren
gerichtsurteile der rechtsprechung
stattfinden ganz klar es werden menschen
dagegen klar ist ja auch noch ein
relativ ich sage mal schwammiger der
interpretationsbedürftige begriff was
angemessen ist was notwendig ist jetzt
heißt es hier auch in dem beschluss wenn
ich gerade noch mal nachschauen
es ist darf triftige gründe müssen
vorliegen gibt es ganz viele fragen sehe
ich hier bei uns im chat was ist ein
triftiger grund ich nehme jetzt mal
beispielsweise fanrat 2020 auf youtube
gefragt ist es ein ist ein umzug
aufgrund von schwangerschaft ein
wichtiger grund um sich weiter als 15
kilometer zu bewegen andere haben gerade
gefragt ich muss noch mal kurz hier in
unserer gesammelte kommentare schauen
da waren muss man mal schauen gerade das
wohnungsbesichtigungen ist das ein
wichtiger grund also solche sachen
tatsächlich wie woran kann ich nicht
orientieren weil ein triftiger grund wie
es in dem papier heißt ist ja doch
auslegungssache oder man muss
grundsätzlich mal festhalten
diese hier ist ein politischer beschluss
der ist ganz allgemein das ist noch
nicht rechtskräftig das muss erst noch
präzisiert werden von den bundesländern
in form von je nachdem wie sie es wollen
gesetze wahrscheinlich eher nicht die
werden verordnung machen wird vielleicht
allgemeinverfügungen geben das heißt ist
hier eine allgemeine politische
absichtserklärung die dann von den
ländern noch in eine korrekte und
präzise rechtsform übersetzt wird das
wird ist auch noch ein paar tage dauern
so und das kann durchaus auch von land
zu land unterschiedlich sein weil das
eben die länder für sich entscheiden wie
sie das genauer formulieren und wie sie
das genauer regeln
man kann sicher sagen dass der weg zur
arbeit ein triftiger grund des man kann
sicher sagen der weg zum arzt eine in
eine spezialklinik muss auch beim umzug
vermutlich wenn jemand aus seiner
wohnung raus muss hat einzugstermin dann
wird auch das mit sicherheit ein
triftiger grund seien aber was man
ansonsten noch genau das tut oder nicht
dann wissen wir einfach abwarten wie die
einzelnen bundesländer das für sich
genau regeln
rechnest du damit dass es klagen gegeben
wird gegen diese
bewegungseinschränkungen die a natürlich
es gibt ja auch schon einen politischen
widerstand wir werden sicherlich einige
schon aus grundsätzlichen erwägungen
heraus klagen
und da wird es würde ich mal vermuten
vielleicht auch durchaus
unterschiedliche gerichtsurteile geben
wie gesagt die kritischen stimmen habe
ich eben genannt von juristen kommen ich
habe aber auch das urteil und dass die
entscheidung zum eilantrag in sachsen
verwiesen die gesagt hat diese 15
kilometer regel ist in ordnung wie
schnell kann das dann gehen also wenn
jetzt sich jemand sofort fleißig
hinsetzt und sagt dagegen juristisch vor
kann das dann schon so fit werden bevor
das tatsächlich in eine verordnung
gegossen wurde dann muss man das allein
ist muss auf jeden fall erstmal rechts
förmig sein also muss in kraft sein
und dann
muss jemand an einen eilantrag stellen
das heißt es wird dann eine vorläufige
entscheidung geben keine endgültige und
wenn damals wegen einen kein gericht zu
der ansicht kommt ja das ist ja ganz
offensichtlich daneben diese regelung
eines bestimmten bundeslandes zur
umsetzung dieser 50 kilometer regel dann
wird womöglich das auch durch ein
eilantrag schnell gekippt werden können
das heißt im endeffekt kann das so
ablaufen wie bei den
demonstrationsverboten letztes jahr dass
die dann einzeln kippen und den
einzelnen bundesländern oder in
einzelnen landkreisen dann finde ich das
auch erst mal tatsächlich dann doch
wieder erlaubt werden also dass die
bewegungs beschränkung dann doch wieder
fällt das ist denkbar
allerdings können wir beobachten dass
die rechtsprechung jetzt in der 2 gronau
welle nicht mehr so unterschiedlich ist
wie in der ersten welle ich glaube dass
generell lesen der zweiten welle man
auch in der justiz auch bei den richtern
doch deutlicher die gefahren und die
notwendigkeit ihrer bekämpfung sieht als
man das zum frühjahr getan hat diese 15
kilometer ist das eigentlich etwas was
anfechtbar ist dass man sagt das sind
willkürlich gezogen da werd dafür gibt
es keine wissenschaftliche begründung
deswegen kann ich den kann er nicht
gelten
halte ich für unwahrscheinlich denn der
staat muss ja irgendeine zahl nennen und
egal welche zahl nennt auch wenn er sagt
14 kilometer auch wenn er versagt 17
kilometer kann immer irgend jemand
kommen und sagen wieso gerade 14 wieso
gerade 15 wieso gerade 17
also irgendwo muss eine grenze gesetzt
werden die 15 kilometer klingen ja
relativ vernünftig weil man in einem 15
kilometer umgreifen der stadt sowieso
aber auf dem land meistens die meisten
menschen zur arbeit fahren können
einkaufen können selbst zur arbeit
fahren könnten sich auch weiter wären
triftiger grund dass die alltäglichen
dinge als selbst der die fahrt zum
einkaufen ist ja bei den allermeisten
menschen nicht länger als 15 kilometer
also wir werden abwarten müssen was dort
genau drin steht deswegen alle sehr
spezifischen fragen die wir hier
bekommen darf ich meine freundin noch
treffen darf ich meinen bruder besuchen
und so weiter können wir jetzt gerade
noch nicht beantworten weil wir einfach
abwarten müssen was die
einzelnen bundesländer dann in diese
verordnungen schreiben könnte vielen
dank für die erste einschätzung für die
beantwortung unserer fragen dazu und
dann möchte ich doch noch mal mit euch
zusammen über die wissenschaftlichen
aspekte der derzeitigen entwicklung
sprechen und dazu haben wir heute abend
professor thorsten leer professor für
klinische pharmazie an der uni des
saarlandes für uns gewinnen können der
einen coup simulator gebastelt hat dann
haben wir hier vor einigen wochen auch
schon mal gemeinsam angeguckt hallo herr
professor dr
hallo einwohnerschwund sie haben ja doch
mit den zahlen wiederum gespielt und
haben mal geguckt was könnte wie
passieren können sie uns sagen was die
bisherigen maßnahmen ihre berechnungen
zufolge gebracht haben
ja also das ist ja gerade eine
pressekonferenz auch schon angeklungen
dass die bisherigen zahlen bis mit
vorsicht zu genießen sind weil wir
halten möglicherweise melde verzug haben
oder auch nicht genug getestet wurde
wenn wir aber einfach mal davon ausgehen
dass die zahlen die wir bekommen haben
stimmen dann würde man so sehen dass
dieser rtw dieser reproduktions wehrt
sich erst mal ab sinkt auf ungefähr eine
zahl von 0,82 in deutschland jetzt kann
man sagen hurra de ist unter 1 das ist
auch richtig das wäre schon ein erfolg
wir gehen im moment davon aus das rege
leben unterschätzen weil die fallzahlen
nicht ganz richtig gemeldet wurden
also war bedenklich ist wenn wir auch
davon ausgehen würden dass diese zahl
eigentlich richtig wäre wenn ich die
tatsache dass diese absenkung einfach
noch überhaupt nicht genug ist und dass
eben diese besagte verschärfung von
heute eigentlich genau der richtige weg
ist um diese zahlen nicht noch weiter zu
drücken eben vor allem unter dem
angesicht das eben wie gesagt die zahlen
nicht stimmen und mir wahrscheinlich
diesen wert aktuell unterschätzen
ich habe mal eine präsentation von ihnen
aufgerufene die sie erhalten haben für
die staatskanzlei und dort geht es zum
beispiel um ich muss man gehen auf die
zart seite 2 die sieben tage das
incident unter rt wird in deutschland
können sie das was sie da jetzt gerade
sehen vielleicht mal ein bisschen
erläutern damit ich damit wir das
verstehen das sind sehr viele kurven
eine rote kurve das ist glaube ich die
sieben tage instituts und das blaue ist
der wert ich hoffe das kann man bei euch
zu hause jetzt auch einigermaßen gut auf
den bildschirm erkennt nicht noch ein
bisschen größer
können sie das vielleicht einmal kurz
erläutern was das genau heißt und genau
das ist ein bisschen so ein rückblick
sowie historie der pandemie also der
erste opel den mann da vorne sieht das
ist quasi der erste pick die erste welle
so zu sagen ja das glaube ich genau was
da wichtig ist es eigentlich dass der
peak eigentlich immer unter 50 grad das
will ich an dieser stelle festhalten
wann immer wir diesen 50er incidents
genannt wird also dass wir dann noch
sehen diese blauen linie was diese
diskurse die referenz linie für den
erwerb der erwerb ist quasi im
hintergrund diese kleine graue
gestrichelte linie als ihn der dichter
ich eigentlich sagen will ist dass nach
der das nach diesem ersten pick ging es
erstmal wieder runter das war schön und
hat mir einen entspannten sommer aber
dann sehen wir endlich das ab juli
eigentlich dieser wert schon beginnt
wieder zu steigen und über heinz ist das
heißt also genau das ist das heißt die
ganze zeit ab hier da vorne ist ein
kleiner opel das war toll news da ist
quasi der tennis ausbruch gewesen da
hatten wir diese vielen infektion
plötzlich mal aber danach war ein
bisschen frieden und dann letztendlich
ging es im juli schon wieder los und
haben das darf man halt eigentlich nicht
ganz vergessen dass du selbst bei diesen
niedrigen instanzen die wir da hat zu
dem zeitpunkt hatten wir in sident in
deutschland weil von drei oder vier oder
so was also die waren sehr sehr niedrig
100 fälle am tag und da fing es eben
schon an zu steigen permanent
anzusteigen
aber ein bisschen letztendlich ja in den
harten lockdown letztendlich
übergegangen sind bis dahin ist es
entweder kunst dann gleich geblieben mit
einem mehrwert von von 1 ungefähr genau
da hat man mal so ein kleines plantschen
in doktor leid und dann ging es im
dezember halt eben wieder rund sozusagen
ja aber dieses plateau da oben was wir
sehen es möglicherweise hat auch durch
die ende änderte am test strategie des
rk ii zurückzuführen genau die haben
nämlich ab november quasi beschlossen
nur noch zu testen wer auch
symptomatisch ist das heißt er
symptomatisch war keine symptome zeigte
wie fieber schnupfen husten wurde ihnen
auch nicht mehr getestet um das
entsprechend einzusparen und paste ist
letztendlich halt eigentlich interessant
weil es halt eben zeit dass in der
historie das eigentlich die ganze zeit
schon quasi auf beschleunigung stand
dieses system und was wir jetzt hier
sehen war nicht komplett unabsehbar aber
natürlich war es bei den frühen zahlen
die wir da vorne hatten eben noch nicht
wirklich gut verkauft mal wieder lockt
machen wir da sollte man eben genau
darüber nachdenken jetzt bei dem
nächsten lockdown ab wann wollen wir
denn eigentlich wieder lockern
weil nämlich diese incidents eben von 50
die ja immer wieder im raum steht
da kann ich mich nur wiederholen die ist
letztendlich eine die wir eben noch
nicht mal in der spitze des ersten pigs
erreicht haben und wenn wir da wieder
lockern würde dann irgendwie wie bei
einem jojo gerade wieder loslegen ja so
professor lehr wir sprechen gleich
nochmal weiter aber für alle zuschauer
innen die vielleicht gerade jetzt erst
dazu gekommen sind oder schon ein
bisschen dabei sind aber die
pressekonferenz verpasst haben wollen
wir doch noch mal einmal ganz kurz
zusammenfassen was dort heute
beschlossen wurde zwischen der
bundesregierung und den regierungen oder
ministerpräsidenten der bundesländer die
haben nämlich für neue maßnahmen gesorgt
und die maßnahmen die bisher gelten
verlängert ansatz stern hat dass wir uns
zusammengefasst
alle bestehenden anti virus maßnahmen
werden bis zum 31 januar verlängert
gastronomie und einzelhandel bleiben
also bis dahin geschlossen genau wie
schulen und auch kitas zusätzlich werden
die kontakt beschränkungen noch einmal
verschärft privat darf man nur noch eine
weitere person treffen die nicht aus dem
eigenen haushalt kommt und in regionen
mit mehr als 200 neuinfektionen pro
100000 einwohner in sieben tagen wird
die bewegungsfreiheit eingeschränkt ohne
einen sogenannten triftigen grund darf
man dann maximal 15 kilometer weg vom
eigenen zuhause
wir sprechen darüber mit professor
draußen leer professor für klinische
pharmazie an der uni des saarlandes der
einkäufe simulator mit seinem team
zusammen programmiert hat um zu schauen
was denn bestimmte änderungen jetzt
bringen würden da ist dass die ag offen
also die offenkundige frage an sie die
maßnahmen die wir gerade gehört haben
halten sie die für sinnvoll dass wir
tatsächlich auch wieder ein bereich
gekommen wo man dann auch wieder über
lockerungen nachdenken kann also was man
festhalten muss es natürlich das erstmal
die kontakt beschränkungen privaten ich
für richtig halte auch wenn ich
natürlich persönlich nicht begrüßen die
man von uns mag das wirklich noch weiter
eingeschränkt zu sein
ich persönlich hatte
natürlich diese beschränkung des radios
bei einer inzidenz von 200 eigentlich zu
hoch wenn ich ehrlich bin ich denke
werten das hänge ich habe einen früheren
in sie denn schon am fahren müssen und
natürlich auch solche ausflüge und
ähnliches mit ähnlichem zu verhindern
also ich glaube wir müssen einfach
bedenken dass wir in der aktuellen
situation wirklich ein sehr hohes
infektionsgeschehen immer noch haben und
versuchen müssen dass maximal in den
keller zu treiben so weit ist
letztendlich geht weiter gefahren
wir sind dazu irgendwelche schon studien
oder wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse was
eine beschränkung des bewegungsradius
tatsächlich bringt nein leider leider
nicht so wirklich
es gibt heute einfach und darlehen sich
jetzt auch diese maßnahmen haben
letztendlich an andere länder wie
beispielsweise frankreich wo man das
letztendlich praktiziert hat und dadurch
gesehen hat das ist ein effekt der sie
müssen zumindest keine studien bekanntes
marketing welche geben aber letztendlich
schränke seien fast meinen dass
natürlich reisen wie zum beispiel mit
der sportgebiet oder ähnliches
stattfinden was aktuell natürlich schön
ist aber in dem infektionsgeschehen
nicht unbedingt ja beiträgt oder nicht
nicht zumindest nicht negativ dazu
beiträgt die gibt es einige fragen an
sie professor lehr zum beispiel per mail
von andreas martin der möchte wissen
warum werden eigentlich immer nur
leichte anpassungen der beschränkungen
vorgenommen warum nicht einfach mal für
zwei wochen eine absolute beschränkung
keinen kommt keinen kontakt kleiner
radius nur für sportler spaziergänge
könnte man dadurch die ganze situation
nicht einfacher und schneller eingrenzen
er absolut das wäre ehrlich gesagt auch
mein mann meine empfehlung also einmal
lieber ein ende mit schrecken als ein
schrecken ohne ende weil das wie sie
sagen es sind immer nur leicht anpassen
letztendlich die informationen die mir
da immer auch aus der rechtsprechung
kommt ist das natürlich eben das aus
rechtsprechungs gründen relativ
kompliziert wäre aber ein harter ein
harter kurzer locker und würde uns
letztendlich deutlich schneller wieder
an die grenze bringen als dieses der
hinkel stotterer was wir momentan
erleben beieinander andere frage an sie
von kazi mamets auf youtube ist hat der
doktor bisher etwas gebracht wenn ja was
es fällt mir schwer zu glauben dass es
einen defekt gegeben hat ja doch also
das gilt natürlich auch immer wieder zu
unterstreichen das natürlich sowohl auf
der lok downlight schon so ein leichter
effekt zumindest gehabt hat dass es
bleibt aber ein bisschen schwierig zu
beurteilen weil eben gleichzeitig auch
der rückgang war der der er das oder die
änderungen dieser dieser messinstrumente
des rk ist der harte locker und jetzt
bringt auf jeden fall schon was das
sehen wir die frage wird halt schlicht
weigern von nur sein was passiert jetzt
noch bei den reiserückkehrern was
passiert eben über die
silvesterfeierlichkeiten und
möglicherweise auch die
weihnachtsfeierlichkeiten da hatten wir
ja auch anfangs schon mal drüber
gesprochen im letzten jahr was wir da
halt einfach hoffentlich vorsichtig
waren weil wir dann jetzt die fallzahlen
in der nächsten zeit sehen werden und
wenn wir heute die fallzahlen uns
anschauen dann sind in meinen augen
schon wieder besorgniserregend hoch also
ich bin gespannt wie sich diese woche
entwickelt aber ich sehe noch nicht sehr
positiv verziehen die nächste woche rein
das ist vielleicht ein guter zeitpunkt
um mal auf genau diese zahlen zu gucken
wir haben das mal versucht zusammen zu
fassen was da die letzten tage
eigentlich passiert ist mein kollege
anselm stern etwas vorbereitet und
wieder ein corona krisengipfel der grund
die korona zahlen in deutschland 11 1897
neue infektionen innerhalb eines tages
wurden dem robert koch institut gemeldet
und 944 neue todesfälle in verbindung
mit dem virus bei der interpretation der
zahlen aber ist vorsicht geboten rund um
die feiertage gab es große verzögerungen
beim entdecken erfassen und übermitteln
der fälle zu sehen an den gewaltigen
schwankungen bei den täglichen
fallzahlen mehr als 30.000 am 30
dezember weniger als 10.000 am 3
die zahlen lage in den krankenhäusern
bleibt angespannt 5678 cupid patienten
liegen derzeit auf deutschen
intensivstationen 4506 intensivbetten
sind laut dem kliniken stand heute
mittag noch frei ich habe wir haben es
gerade auch schon bei der
pressekonferenz der bundeskanzlerin mit
den ministerpräsidenten gehört so
richtig ist nicht richtig bekannt wie
viele ansteckungszahlen wifi zierte es
eigentlich gibt wie aussagekräftig
finden sie die zahlen eigentlich also
wie gesagt dass es gerade sehr schwer
eigentlich zu interpretieren ich denke
mal wir haben dafür halt eben auch unser
modell bemüht weil das modell an
manchmal auch zeigt was eigentlich nicht
richtig ist was man vielleicht noch
betrachten muss ist das beispielsweise
auch die falsch die nicht die falls
sondern die positive rate wieder
deutlich gestiegen ist was auch wieder
eine lizenz dafür ist das eigentlich die
dunkelziffer deutlich wir das sehen wir
in der letzten zeit sehr deutlich vor
allem seit das robert koch institut die
test strategie umgestellt hat und vor
allem auch in der letzten woche das ist
deutlich angestiegen
das heißt also ich glaube schon dass wir
hier nun der schätzung haben aber genau
werden wir das leider halt auch nicht
wissen und das wird möglicherweise auch
nicht zu klären sondern wir werden dann
jetzt eben nur sehen wie sich die
fallzahlen in den nächsten tagen
entwickeln werden am primär können wir
jetzt leider halt auch gar nicht machen
weil möglicherweise infizierte auch ihre
infektion einfach durchgestanden haben
ohne sich testen zu lassen über die
weihnachtsfeiertage
also von daher wir sicherlich einen
gewissen blumen den wir zu weihnachten
generiert haben mit dem wir dann jetzt
anfang januar mit einer messe auf eine
datenerfassung endlich wieder versuchen
müssen zu leben und land zu kommen da
gibt es eine passende frage zu auf
youtube das heißt also dass die
dunkelziffer gezwungenermaßen um einiges
höher ist weil asymptomatische
krankheitsverläufe wie nie gab es gar
nicht mehr erfasst werden er absolut und
das halte ich persönlich auch für
ehrlich gesagt gefährlich weil stellen
sie sich mal vor sie sind jetzt jemand
der nur in quarantäne geschickt wird
weil er kontakt mit einem kugel
verlassen hatte und sie sind dann in
quarantäne und sind nicht getestet und
wie verhalten sie sich ich behaupte
persönlich sie verhalten sich anders
wenn sie wissen dass sie positiv
getestet sind also wenn sie nur ein
potenzieller
potenzial der fall sind also von daher
halte ich wie gesagt diese diese test
strategie für gefährlich und wünsche
würde mir wünschen dass sie umgeschwenkt
wird aber die aktuelle test kapazität
lässt einfach leider kein anderes
vorgehen zu es gibt ja eine kritische
frage auf youtube von volker rusty da
geht es um die instanzen weil er fragt
sich warum jetzt nur noch um diese
incidents zahlen sind die eher werte zu
klein als dass man dieser technik jetzt
benutzen könnte er hat quasi ein
bisschen insinuiert dass man damit angst
machen möchte eine eigentlich die die
rwth selben wir haben vielleicht ein
bisschen in der popularität verloren
aber eigentlich ist die dieser er wert
ist eigentlich letztendlich der
beschleunigungs faktor der sagt uns wie
stark sich die inzidenz ansteigt oder
absinkt wo sich nichts mehr wert wir
liegen jetzt deutschlandweit momentan
bei 0,82 und das was ich schon sagte ist
genau eigentlich in meinen augen das
gefährliche das selbst bin ich bedenke
dass diese zahlen gerade wahrscheinlich
unterschätzt sind das heißt dass dieser
wert niedriger ist als real ist der noch
nicht niedrig genug das heißt also die
absenkung würde sehr sehr langsam
vorangehen so wenn das so weitergehen
würde wir momentan und das ist
letztendlich genau man bedenken dass
heißt diese 50er incident würden wir
eigentlich auch erst mitte februar in
etwa deutschlandweit erreichen und das
war natürlich sehr lange und das was ich
schon sagte 50 wäre eigentlich überhaupt
nicht das ziel wo ich über lockerung
wieder nachdenken würde das ist dann
doch noch mal kurz ein obmann ich habe
dann auch die bundeskanzlerin im ort die
bei einer ihrer vielen pressekonferenzen
sagte der erwerb muss unter 1 das ist ja
jetzt dann könnte man natürlich sagen wo
ist das problem
da könnte ich noch mal auf ihre
präsentation zurückkommen weil sie haben
das gerade gesagt sie haben berechnet
wie das tatsächlich aussieht
es gibt ein start von ihnen favorisierte
mit dem mit den instituten oder mit den
ansteckungszahlen bei einer verschärfung
oder einer nicht verschärfung ich glaube
das ist die fall dass falsche chart ich
nehme mal dass der anschein lich oder
harter lockdown die man auch weiter bei
einem eher wert von 0,6 oder soll ich
das davor nehmen mit dem mehrwert von
mir können sie können auch folie vor die
sieben nehmen poly 7 sind die beiden
nebeneinander kontrastiert das ist
einfach mal genau da die genau
ja was was man mit diesem erbe sagen
musste der wert ist ein bisschen wie
wenn sie auf eine bremse treten beim
auto nur weil sie auf eine bremse treten
halten sich zwangsläufig anmerkt der
erwerb sei erklärte nicht wie hart ich
meine haken da drauf und wenn er wird
sehr klein ist dann haben sie vor sehr
stark auf die bremse und bremsen sehr
stark das sind hier oben rechts die dass
das zarte geschlecht des paradis und
dann geht das steigert ist ferner ob
genau das quasi ab diesem gestrichelten
strich das wäre jetzt über morgen wird
nochmal annehmen dass der wert von 0,82
auf 0,6 ab sinkt also ich würde mir
letztendlich und auf der linken seite
will man davon ausgehen dass es quasi so
weitergeht mit einem wert von 0,82
das würde aber bedeuten dass sie diese
50er inzidenz und das ist in der tabelle
angegeben beim ablesen kann man das
relativ schlecht dass diese 50er
sidentin dem linken fall also wenn alles
gleich bleibt wie eigentlich erst am 10
februar ungefähr durchbrechen würden und
bei einer verschärfung jetzt wie wir es
jetzt hier angenommen haben ungefähr bei
dem am 6 26 ersten schauen und das
gleiche sehen wir dann für andere
maßzahlen wenn wir 25 er ins tänzen uns
anschauen wenn es bei einem
gleichbleibenden eben anfang märz
beziehungsweise einer verschärfung
anfang februar also das heißt da sieht
man schon diesen effekt und da muss man
eben auch aufpassen dass er werte unter
unter 1 war schon mal positiv sind weil
wir kein wachstum beinhalten aber die
frage ist halt wie stark senke ich da
ist es deswegen ist es halt auch sehr
wichtig dass wir jetzt wirklich das sehr
deutlich absenken damit wir dort
wirklich mal in niedrigere gefüllten
reihen kommen weil eben bei einer
lockerung oder umsetzung danach oder
einer wiedereröffnung von geschäften
oder ähnlichen würde
höchstwahrscheinlich das
infektionsgeschehen wieder weitergehen
weil wir würden uns immer noch in einer
sehr virus freundlichen umgebung
befinden das heißt wir hätten dann
wahrscheinlich februar oder ähnliches
die witterungsbedingungen noch schlecht
wir haben das gesehen
die erste welle war letztendlich hat im
februar angefangen über mehr als
zusätzlicher perfekte bedingungen auf
sich weiter zu verbreiten
da müssen wir uns natürlich nichts
vormachen aber die die grund
durchseuchung wenn ich das mal flapsig
sagen das ist natürlich jetzt eine viel
viel höherer ist das was wir im frühjahr
2020 hatten jetzt haben sie gerade schon
gesagt er der der inzidenz wert muss
unter 50 bundesweit
oder sie sind an nichts mit dieser zahl
nicht einverstanden ist muss noch weiter
runter haben sie gesagt da es gibt hier
eine frage jetzt abschließend von
florian a auf youtube wie soll das denn
gehen also werden wir uns angucken wie
hoch der inzidenz wert teilweise ist in
den einzelnen landkreisen haben wir
leider gesehen noch einmal für alle zum
nachgucken auf der zdf heute bei uns
gibt es eine karte dazu da kann man sich
den eigenen landkreis mal anschauen
das klingt ein bisschen utopisch muss
ich sagen oder also man kann das
natürlich schon erreichen wenn sich
letztendlich die infektion jetzt wieder
deutlich einschränken deswegen hoffe ich
halte auch dass diese kontakt
beschränkungen noch ein bisschen helfen
und das natürlich jetzt auch die
feierlichkeiten von weihnachten
weihnachtsshopping und ähnlichem wieder
zurück gefahren sind sich wieder ein
bisschen vielleicht auch wieder
besinnung breit macht letztendlich
müssen wir einfach bedenken wir machen
das für uns investiert hierfür uns in
unsere gesundheit und zukunft
wir müssen jetzt endlich schauen dass
wir eben runter kommen auch bevor die
zweite die mutation kommen weil die
würde letztendlich fiel uns an maßnahmen
wieder zunichte machen und letztendlich
heißt es hier einfach durchhalten bis
die impfung da ist und das kann leider
halt noch ein langer weg werden
aber wir wissen halt auch und das was
sie gerade schon angesprochen werden
teilweise landkreise und bundesländer
mit so ich sehe ihn ins tänzen wir
werden unterschiedlich das ziel
erreichen also die erfahren wir quasi
mit unterschiedlichen geschwindigkeiten
und bundesländer wie beispielsweise
mecklenburg vorpommern die werden das
wahrscheinlich vier wochen früher
erreichen als beispielsweise sachsen und
auch da gibt es jetzt in meinen augen
noch keine regelungen wie damit
umgegangen wird wenn wir beispielsweise
noch einen relativ hoch ins identen
staat wie sachsen haben und in
mecklenburg vorpommern wird gelockert
das müssen wir mal schauen was sich da
die ministerpräsidenten einfallen lassen
aber das ist ein thema was jetzt auch
noch nicht aufgegriffen wurde was ich
immer noch als problematisch sehe also
da kommen neue probleme am horizont wir
beschäftigen uns aber erstmals mit denen
den wir gerade haben das bleibt
kompliziert professor thorsten der
vielen dank für ihre einschätzungen
heute abend und alle informationen
natürlich zu den beschlüssen der
bundesregierung zusammen mit den
ministerpräsidenten der bundesländer
gibt es bei uns auch zeit erfreute de
zusammengefasst zusammen in unserer
karte wo man sich informieren kann wie
die jeweilige institut zahl aussieht in
den jeweiligen landkreisen oder auch
natürlich in der zdf-reihe abwehr sind
noch nicht hat da sie gerne runterladen
da gibt es noch einmal eine push
nachricht wenn wir wieder live gehen
dass wenn wir mal
mit sicherheit wieder tun aber für heute
sage ich erst mal vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit bleibt gesund und macht
euch einen schönen abend bis dann und
tschüss